[Music]
hello
today we'll be talking about how to make
your data in a bucket public to
everyone on the internet this means that
your data will be readable to everyone
on the internet
i've created a bucket called tiny homes
in this bucket i'll be storing photos of
tiny homes
as you can see right now all the images
are private
but i want to make these images public
so people can access them
so the first step is to open the cloud
storage browser
in google cloud console when we are in
the bucket
we can see all the files that live in
the bucket
so to make a single file public what we
want to do is we want to click
the actions menu which is the three
little bars
to the side of the file
we want to select edit permissions from
the drop down menu
then we want to add a new entity the
entity name should be public
then all users and then reader and then
just click save
and as you can see we have a link that
we can share with anyone who wants to
view
this specific file in the bucket but
let's say we want to make all the images
in this folder public
it would be tedious to do the actions
that we performed earlier to every item
in the bucket so what we can do is we
can click the edit permissions button
add a new member called all users
set their role as storage object viewer
in the cloud storage section
and that's it we've made every image in
our bucket public
you